monte monte monte toujours plus haut
pour voir le monde à la recherche d'une
certaine tranquillité et de l'entr'aide
en créant vu dans anno frachon chercher
de la magie pour voir au delà c voire
d'un os tout ce qui se passe en bas
c'est éviter éviter tout ce qui est
douloureux
c'est
c'est la proche de la beauté de la
légèreté le représente la pureté et pour
faire cette colonne de coussins c'était
indispensable pour moi d'avoir du blanc
si je l'avais fait en pierre ou en béton
ça n'aurait pas dû tout donner la même
chose comme ndo frachon 11 autres
artistes sont exposés le 9e salon des
arts de plaisir laisse une grande place
aux artistes yvelinois comme fabienne dû
mouiller a passionné de musique qui
travaillent des matériaux recyclés des
guitares destiné à la destruction où
vivent entre ses mains dès que j'ai
commencé j'ai trouvé que les arrondis se
prêtait à vraiment très facilement à la
décoration et la difficulté de suivre un
contour qui n'est pas rectiligne
c'est c'est presque là la motivation et
un petite réflexion sur le plat et le
vide
une image fractionné implique un contour
et second tour doit être l'intérieur
d'une autre image
une treizième artistes alimente
l'exposition véronique l'avenir est
l'invité d'honneur de cette nouvelle
édition
cette sculptrice travaille le bronze
pour des oeuvres où l'humain fragile
cherche sa place